نستعرض الجدل الدائره في فرنسا بشان اوضاع
سيئه للعاملين في المنشات الرياضيه التي
ستحتضن فعاليات الالعاب الاولمبيه باريس
تحت وسم قاطع باريس 2024 صارت عاصفه من
الانتقادات في الاوساط السياسيه والرياضيه
بعد كشف الستار عن ظروف سيئه يعانيها كثير
من هؤلاء العمال
الجدل بشان هذا الموضوع تصعد اكثر بعد ما
بثت قناه اخباريه فرنسيه تحقيقا قصيرا
يعرض الظروف والسحر الصعبه التي يمارس
فيها يمارس فيها عمال الافارقه عملهم في
هذه المنشات ونقلت القناه شهادات لبعض
العمال تحدثوا فيه عن حرمالهم من حقوق
اساسيه كالاجور والمبيت في مساكن عمل
لائقه وتحدث احدهما عن استغلال مستخدمهم
لاوضاعهم غير القانونيات من حيث الاقامه
وابتزازهم بها حيث انتظر 10 اشهر كامله
ليتسلم راتب شهر واحد
التفاعل امتد مع الموضوع الى ناشطين
ورياضيين دعوا الى التمديد مجددا بما يحدث
للعمال في منشاه الاولمبياد التي ستحتضنها
العاصمه الفرنسيه من بين ابرز التفاعلات
حساب اكتفوت
وغرد بالقول العمال الذين من غير الوثائق
الابتزاز الذين يتعرضون له في مواقع
البناء لمنشات اولمبياد باريس 2014 يقول
كثير منهم انهم لم يتلقوا رواتبهم كامله
اللاعب الدولي السابق ابراهيم تيام تساءل
في تغريدته اين هو مقدموا الدروس انظروا
الى ما يجري عندكم قبل ان تنظروا الى ما
يجري عند غيركم بينما غرد صاحب الحساب
المسمى اكسل فيلد موجها سؤالا لرئيسه
بلديته باريس سيده
حمله لمقاطعه اولمبياد 2024